you have all this knowledge and you'd
like to what's your future you know what
it what do you what do you want to do
well that's a good question and you know
you did ask me to ask you ask me about
my future tell me my that's why you hold
your palm I am on your show to promote
something oh what's that
let me say this when I left the Senate I
said I'm giving up my seat I'm not
giving up my voice mm-hmm so Sirius XM
radio is I have a show now on that will
be on Saturdays and I I chose to I want
to address issues that are important to
people's lives which did not happen in
16 it was all the Trump circus and
Hilary emails and so I've had people on
you know on health care on the courts on
climate but I've also had Dana Carvey
hilarious Dana Carvey yeah and my first
guest on the radio show now I mean I is
as Chris Rock oh yeah I've heard of him
yeah and my second guest is Harry Reid
that's an interesting show where you're
get because there we've got Chris Rock
and Harry Reid you know there's not a
you know what I mean there's not a
straight line necessarily when it when I
do the interview with Harry Reid mm-hm
I'm the funny one
right and when I do it with with Chris
I'm I'm the one who spent eight and a
half years in the center I got yeah yeah
but Chris actually has an interesting
that you know busing huge issue
yeah well it
not really but I mean it became it
became an issue in the debates with
Komal Harrison Biden yeah but the reason
it really isn't issues is that you know
if we don't really do it right now and
but and one of the reasons is Chris's
experience he was bust for nine years
and he told me it was an hour two and an
hour from he said I'm competing against
kids who had an hour more sleep than I
do and he in many years was the only
black boy yeah and he asked me he said
in the nine years guess how many times I
was invited over to another kids house
after school
how many once once in nine years
once the nine you who invited him over
I forgot his first name it's Moskowitz
don't laugh at the man's lab you know no
I was acting I was laughing with joy I
was laughing with joy at the great
generosity of the Jewish people
[Laughter]
you were the only one to stand I know
they got a Gentile audience yeah that's
great you it sounds like you've got some
great guests coming up what you know
would I make it on this show yes you
would you in fact we're doing I'm gonna
be doing you're right you do my podcast
podcast and I'm gonna make my radio show
out of it No
do you paint you a little pay me or
something for that a little something
you'll get that so I'll get so we're
it's a twofer kind of what we're doing
no we're gonna have guests like you know
like Patton Oswalt look very funny Chris
Rock
yeah like airy read like Michelle Obama
not Michelle Obama but guests like her
[Applause]